previously on TV since I've been on the
job about three months tell them two
previous cases or open-and-shut mostly I
just sat around out during this year to
looking at the ground I don't have no
floor out there
[Music]
for over a century I have lived in
secret member Asian at this point we're
all just waiting on the CW to release a
show that is 100% narration called the
narration Chronicles it's obviously
their manifest destiny also a century
just a century they're actual humans
that have lived over a century what a
total loop pyre I'm a vampire and this
is my story I believe you mean diary
this is your diary do you not even know
the name of the show you're on an hour's
drive to hear that crap you know wasn't
even a band a guy with a guitar
douchebag hipster is a dick to solo
artists he's sounded like James Blunt Oh
what's wrong with that we already have a
James Blunt one is all we need drama
dead body falls on a car to create a
jump scare even though there is no
reason the perpetrator would have a way
to have thrown it there without being
seen cliche first I thought this show
was called the vampire dairies and was
about a group of vampires that owned a
dairy farm so that they could both feed
off the livestock as well as make an
honest living
and now I'm mad because I'd rather be
watching that show instead and I had no
choice I have to know her I see we are
warming up the old pronoun game nice and
early for maximum irrelevance
sweet dear diary and now we are on to
die racin which is different from
diarrhea Asian for obvious reasons
though considering the CW track record
I'm guessing we will get that eventually
I will smile and it will be believable I
smile will say I'm fine if this is a
modeling you are in your journal entries
then you deserve all the pink guide
defang vampires you can manage ignoring
the conveniently relevant news on the TV
about the couple we saw get eaten in the
cold open let's instead focus on the
fact that they have decided to include a
weather forecast in a small space below
this tragic tale not only that it simply
says sunny with cloudy periods no
temperature no time frame just the basic
information that the Sun will exist
today and Seoul clouds
hey I'm meteorologist Brady Beck and the
day you can expect some temperatures
outside as well as possible levels of
moisture that may or may not stay in the
air or land on the ground meteorologists
grams is telling me I'm psychic
our ancestors were from Salem which
isn't all that I know your grams name
wouldn't happen to be exposition would
it also we're less than four minutes
into the first episode can we see how
the whole vampire portion of the show
goes before we start bringing witches
and psychics into the mix I can't be
freaked out by harsh the rest of my life
well sure but hitting something and
screeching to a halt in the middle of
the road might freak anyone out even
those of us that aren't conspicuously
hinting at a tragic backstory I predicts
this year is going to be kick-ass wrong
ha kick-ass actually came out in April
of 2010 the year after this is set so
much for your psychic abilities unless
of course you've met the school year in
which case kick-ass would have come out
before the school year is that a holy
she is psychic what is it with TV shows
having students hanging out outside the
school before classes start and what
universe do this many kids even arrive
early enough to hang out at all let
alone throw some sort of daily block
party in the school courtyard for that
matter how is it even this light outside
before the beginning of the school day
she looks so hot can I still say [ __ ]
mess no that's over
you also can't get away with hiding
hurtful phrases and self-aware jokes
just because you think that it will
somehow excuse it man I really like
Vicky she is a truly underrated
character in The Vampire Diaries
universe good thing she's not going
anywhere
hey Pete Wentz called he wants his nail
polish back Pete Wentz huh let's go TRL
of you Carson Daly fit not that Steve
McQueen would be excellent at TV since
always use back it's a hot back that's
back sister please look again I'm sure
everything you need is there well you're
right so it is if Stefan had this trick
up his sleeve then why not use it to get
employment or somebody to give him money
in a banker anything other than going to
high school and yes I know he got a
yacht assist later but that doesn't make
it any less sinful also he just used
vampire parlor tricks to make the office
personnel see something different he
didn't actually change his records so
the next time anyone has to look
anything up on him it's still gonna be
bogus how many times into how many
people will he have to pull this Don so
that he can stay in high school
[Music]
pardon me this the men's room convenient
and embarrassing wrong restroom meet
puke sorry meet cute is convenient
shortening the word you and using a
symbol for at I get but hot II Bonnie
would be expounding the exact same
effort to spell out hottie Oh scarecrow
back here there was this this bird and
it was all very Hitchcock for a second
well since it was just the one crow
quote thing Nevermore and all and doing
its best That's So Raven impersonation
I'm gonna have to say it was a bit more
Edgar Allan Poe there for a second
please tell me you're not hooking up
with my sister so this is one of the few
literal cases of going against the bros
before hos ruling Stefan Salvatore he
lives with his uncle up at the old
Salvatore boarding house he hasn't lived
here since he was a kid thing one of the
high school stereotypes we are being
introduced to is the mean girl gossiper
so this discount Buffy the Vampire
Slayer joke and exposition our brains
out whenever it feels like it I want to
apologize for my disappearing act
earlier I know it was strange and I did
this by showing up your house that you
never gave me the address for so as to
not come off any creepier than I already
have
my 1 1 anyone to read mine you have a
journal it's called a diary we have been
through this already it's right in the
freaking title also there's been a lot
more Diaries and a lot less vampires
than I would like so far vampires just
disorganized slobs these diaries Ave am
Frank here are all completely out of
order and all over the place in fact
there are two separate 2005 Diaries
which is fine except that wouldn't you
at least mark 1a and 1b so you know
which one came first this is not a
picture of someone who looks like Elena
this is a picture of Elena yeah yeah
yeah genetics blah blah blah but unless
she's a twin generations removed but
this lithograph is bolt also since when
do 150 some year old lithographs have
that level of detail after aging for
over a century would you like to take
this opportunity to overcome your
embedded jock stereotype ok mr. Tanner
I'm cool and unfortunately so was this
show you know what look if I wanted to
see an extremely soap opera Twilight but
done on a TV production budget with a
cast selected primarily for their looks
I would have just watched Oh Twilight we
did meet in a graveyard
no technically we met in the men's room
no technically you met outside the men's
room don't try to take my job Nina or I
might just have to bring up Flatliners I
find it odd that no one even has a
reaction when Fogg just magically
appears in this town or they simply
don't know how Fogg works and based on
what little we've seen of actual
teaching in the schools this would not
be surprising I get that Stephane is
supposed to be set up as a red herring
for the vampire killings but anyone who
has ever watched a TV show will know
there is zero chance he's the vampire so
ridiculous scenes of him coming out of
the woods when he should have already
been back at the party are well
ridiculous I just wanna let you know
that I still believe in us do your good
gravy got in mashed potato heaven is
this seriously just the blood in the
beautiful the fangs of our lives Beverly
Hills 90210 positive vampire soap opera
suck yeah you and me it's not gonna
happen well considering your over a
hundred years old and these are high
school girls nothing should be happening
with any of them what Jeremy yes
somewhere that isn't yet another show
that combines teenagers and metaphysical
beats and continuing to pretend it's an
interesting mystery when really it's
just an excuse to target and manipulate
a young demographics hormones for
financial gain hopefully I don't want to
hear it good thing we spent the whole B
story this episode on the younger
drug-dealing brother who wanted to
protect Vicky from the one rapey guy
that seems to have paid off nicely now
that she's dead or a vampire or whatever
Dana
hello brother and hello Deon another
show that ridiculously has characters
call out their relationship well
greeting each other solely for the
audience's benefit close a bit much
don't you think where do you see what I
can do with the fog oh I've seen that
plenty Damon and like the rest of Mystic
Falls I'm pretty much over it whatever I
saw or I think I saw I have this feeling
that it's just the beginning well tell
me something when's the last time you
had something stronger than a squirrel
she Boone is coming in hot with this
over-the-top VAM peer pressure I'm not
saying he wouldn't push and tease his
brother like this I'm just saying he
should have grown a mustache so he could
twirl it while he does where's your ring
Suns coming up in a couple hours and
poof ashes to ashes I see the show has
decided to go with the magic ring that
allows vampires to hang out in the day
selection on the convenience menu very
nice choice should pair well with the
chicken
I realize giving him a low number of
about drinking in front of the comps is
a character thing but shouldn't the cops
actually do something the cops in this
town appear to be about as dependable as
they are in most horror movies which is
zilch along with tons of narration and a
cast selected primarily by entering the
key word ability this is a CW show that
seems to follow the strict doctrine of
parents never being around someone
without the past without the pain alive
in their final routine of the evening
the CW is going for the rare
synchronized narration a risky move but
let's see what the judges have to say
thirty sins I'm no single sin narration
record all that narrating is finally
paid off I know it's late but uh I
needed to know that you were okay which
I could have asked you at the party but
I ran away because I'm weird and creepy
what do you tell them that I'll be fine
do you ever mean it it's me tomorrow
this was actual dialog that humans wrote
into a script and made other humans say
out loud also skip
that's why we don't show ourselves in
sunlight look at the size of this thing
it's like Campbell's cappuccino please
look again I'm sure everything you need
is there again my spring my parent's car
drove off of a bridge into the lake and
I was in the backseat and I survived but
they didn't now you know the rest of the
story
brothers got